Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Vous aussi,
vous êtes accro à votre smartphone ?
Connaissez-vous l'histoire du plus
célèbre d'entre eux ?
L'iPhone.
Savez-vous qu'au départ,
personne ne croyait en son succès ?
Et pourtant.
Il a sauvé de la faillite
la société qui l'a créé,
la fameuse marque à la pomme.
Aujourd'hui,
Léo de la chaîne
TechMaker nous raconte
cette fabuleuse épopée.
[son de touches de téléphone]
Allo, Léo ?
Nous sommes pendus à tes lèvres.
Jamy, tu vas voir,
cette histoire est complètement dingue.
Nous sommes le 9 janvier 2007
au Moscone Center de San Francisco.
Steve Jobs, le patron emblématique
de la société Apple,
s'apprête à faire une annonce fracassante
dans le cadre d'une nouvelle
Keynote.
Pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas,
une Keynote, c'est une conférence événement
organisée par la marque à la pomme.
Leur but est de présenter de tout
nouveaux produits.
Aujourd'hui, Jobs va dévoiler
un téléphone qui devrait, selon lui,
bouleverser le monde
de la téléphonie.
Son nom l'iPhone.
Seul sur scène,
il dévoile pour la première fois
son mystérieux téléphone
en prononçant ces mots :
"Un superbe iPod tactile,
un téléphone portable
et un formidable appareil
permettant d'aller sur Internet."
Ce ne sont pas trois appareils,
mais un seul.
Aujourd'hui, Apple va réinventer le téléphone.
En réunissant trois produits en un,
cet appareil se veut
tout simplement révolutionaire.
Pour Jobs, l'enjeu est de taille.
l'iPhone a pour mission de relancer
définitivement Apple,
qui a frôlé la faillite
il y a quelques années.
Mais contre toute attente,
les journalistes
et les spécialistes présents dans la salle
se montrent dubitatifs.
Le patron d'Apple
leur promettait une révolution.
Eh bien, c'est raté.
Son iPhone n'aurait rien d'innovant.
Les premiers téléphones que l'on peut
qualifier d'intelligent
datent des années 90,
et à l'époque, ils ont fait un énorme flop.
C'est le cas du Simon,
commercialisé par IBM en 1994.
Il s'agit du premier téléphone
mobile à écran tactile de l'Histoire.
Il dispose d'un service de messagerie.
Il peut envoyer et recevoir des fax.
Il est aussi équipé
d'un traitement de texte.
Mais cet appareil n'a
jamais trouvé son public.
D'une part,
les gens n'en comprennent pas l'utilité.
D'autre part,
il est beaucoup trop cher : 400€
contre 80€
pour un portable classique de l'époque.
En découvrant l'iPhone, les concurrents
d'Apple ne se privent pas de le critiquer.
Ce smartphone n'a
aucune chance de s'imposer
auprès du grand public.
Aucune.
Affirme-t-on chez Microsoft.
C'est aussi l'avis de Padmasree Warrior,
la directrice des nouvelles technologies chez Motorola.
À l'époque, cette entreprise est l'un
des mastodontes de la téléphonie mobile.
Selon elle,
l'iPhone n'a rien de révolutionnaire.
Interface tactile, capteur de mouvement,
accéléromètre,
reconnaissance de geste,
caméra 2 mégapixels, lecteur MP3 intégré,
Wi-Fi, Bluetooth.
Bref, rien de neuf sous le soleil.
À première vue,
on pourrait penser que les concurrents
de la marque à la pomme font preuve
d'une évidente mauvaise foi.
l'iPhone leur fait-il peur ?
Craignent-ils d'être dépassés ?
Rien de tout cela.
En vérité, leur réaction
est parfaitement compréhensible.
Comment le patron d'Apple peut-il espérer
capter des parts de marché
avec des technologies
déjà disponibles sur les produits
vendus par les leaders de l'industrie
comme
Motorola, Nokia et Samsung ?
Sans parler du prix 399€,
c'est beaucoup trop cher !
Et ce n'est pas tout.
À cette époque,
la firme américaine doit faire face
à d'autres obstacles, et pas des moindres.
En 2007,
les contrats de téléphonie ne sont pas
accessibles comme ils le sont aujourd'hui.
Rien qu'en France,
les prix des forfaits sont démesurés.
Ils ne comprennent pas d'abonnement à Internet
et en prime,
le nombre de SMS et les temps d'appel
sont limités.
Pour profiter de ce fameux iPhone,
on est contraint de l'acheter
avec un forfait Orange,
doublé d'un engagement obligatoire d'au moins 2 ans.
Et enfin, cerise sur le gâteau,
l'appareil
ne propose pas de boutique numérique
permettant de télécharger
de nouvelles applications.
Il faut se contenter de celles
qui sont fournies avec le téléphone,
donc les mails, le calendrier.
Bref, rien de très folichon.
Alors bien sûr,
il y a quand même cet appareil photo
intégré et c'est un bon point.
Mais que vaut-il vraiment ?
En réalité,
ses caractéristiques techniques
sont très limitées et il comporte
un capteur photo de 2 mégapixels.
Autant dire que l'on est loin, très loin,
des 48 mégapixels
présentés
sur le dernier modèle de la marque.
Mais il en faudrait plus
pour entamer le moral de Steve Jobs.
Son iPhone, il y croit dur comme fer.
Il faut dire que le patron d'Apple
est ce qu'on appelle un dur à cuire.
C'est un personnage à part dans la galaxie
des grands patrons du numérique.
Ce n'est pas un technicien,
ce n'est pas un geek non plus.
Jobs était un visionnaire,
un rêveur qui fonctionne à l'intuition.
Certains d'entre vous se souviennent
peut être que 6 ans plus tôt, en 2001,
il avait pris tout le monde de court
avec l'iPod,
un petit baladeur numérique sorti
tout droit de son imagination.
En quelques mois,
cet appareil a complètement changé
notre manière de consommer la musique.
Pour en faire la promotion,
Jobs avait même trouvé
une utilité
à la toute petite poche de nos jeans,
celle qui ne laissait rien pénétrer :
y fourrer son iPod.
Grâce à ce petit bijou de technologie,
le PDG d'Apple
a réussi à relancer la société
qui était au bord du dépôt de bilan.
Une sacrée revanche pour celui
qui avait été viré par la firme
16 ans plus tôt, en 1985.
Grave erreur.
Après son départ, la société connaît
une véritable descente aux enfers.
Elle ne parvient plus à être innovante.
Ses produits sont trop chers.
Elle propose trop de modèles,
les consommateurs
n'y comprennent plus rien
et ils finissent par se tourner
vers les PC, meilleur marché
et plus simple d'utilisation.
Face à ce naufrage,
Apple avait finalement réintégré
Jobs en 1997.
Depuis, rien ne semble l'arrêter.
En ce mois de janvier 2007,
il en est persuadé
on est à l'aube d'une révolution.
Son smartphone pourrait bien faire
d'Apple le nouveau leader mondial
de la téléphonie.
Il faut attendre le 29 juin 2007,
jour de sa mise en vente,
pour savoir si l'intuition de Jobs
était la bonne.
Et comme il le pressentait,
son téléphone connaît immédiatement
un succès phénoménal
qui fait mentir tous les pronostics.
Le réveil est difficile
pour les concurrents d'Apple,
ils n'ont pas compris
que l'iPhone est un produit novateur,
très éloigné des standards de l'époque.
Il est centré sur l'utilisateur,
avec un design
pensé pour lui simplifier la vie.
Pour la première fois, c'est le téléphone
qui s'adapte à l'utilisateur
et non l'inverse.
Un enfant de 4 ans peut comprendre
en 2 secondes comment on s'en sert.
Pas besoin de mode d'emploi.
C'est le secret de son succès.
La simplicité n'était pas un critère
prioritaire pour les autres marques.
Leurs interfaces sont plus austère
les unes que les autres,
les écrans sont aussi bien plus petits.
La faute à un clavier complet
en dessous de leur écran et une molette
pour naviguer entre les applications.
C'est le cas par exemple du BlackBerry.
Dans un univers où les outils sont
peu pratiques et trop complexes, l'arrivée
d'un appareil ludique et attrayant,
c'est du pain béni pour les consommateurs.
Fort de ce succès,
Apple ne perd pas de temps pour améliorer son téléphone.
À peine un an plus tard, le 9 juin 2008,
l'iPhone 3G déboule sur le marché.
Et cette fois,
il met tout le monde d'accord.
Cette nouvelle version est plus aboutie
et elle comporte enfin cette fameuse
boutique d'application qui lui manquait tant.
Et ça, c'est l'AppStore
qui est toujours en service aujourd'hui.
En prime, ce nouveau modèle profite
de l'évolution de la législation.
En France, par exemple,
le Conseil de la concurrence
suspend l'exclusivité d'Orange,
ce qui permet à tout le monde
de s'offrir un iPhone, quel que soit
l'opérateur que l'on a choisi.
Dès lors, l'iPhone
devient le produit incontournable
il n'est plus la chasse gardée
des early adopters.
C'est le nom que l'on donne aux
aficionados des nouvelles technologies.
Cet appareil devient immensément
populaire en quelques mois à peine
et surtout, le mot
smartphone lui est désormais associé.
Nokia, Motorola et tous les concurrents
d'Apple sont au tapis.
Pendant que l'iPhone inonde le marché,
ils s'obstinent à proposer
de vieux téléphones classiques
qui sont désormais perçus par le public
comme des antiquités.
Certains ne s'en relèveront pas.
C'est le cas de BlackBerry,
qui cherche à s'accrocher
jusqu'au bout à son clavier physique.
C'est aussi le cas de Microsoft,
qui tente de lancer son propre
système d'exploitation mobile.
Mais c'est déjà trop tard
et l'Histoire a déjà oublié son nom.
Le Windows Phone, est-ce que ça vous parle encore ?
Pour d'autres,
le réveil est encore plus douloureux.
Motorola, par exemple, qui occupait
la 2ème place juste après Nokia
sur le marché de la téléphonie mobile,
subit une dégringolade sans précédent.
Le retard pris par la concurrence
sera tout de même compensé
par le lancement d'Android
un an plus tard, en 2008.
Mais l'arrivée d'Android
n'entame pas le succès de l'iPhone.
Une étude menée aux Etats-Unis en 2021
montre que
près de 9 jeunes américains sur 10 possèdent un iPhone
directement dans sa poche.
C'est juste faramineux.
Apple est désormais capitalisée
à plus de 1000 milliards de dollars.
La firme co-fondée par Steve Jobs
revient de très, très loin.
Le boss tire sa révérence en 2011,
emporté par un cancer foudroyant.
Mais avant sa mort,
il aura le temps de lancer un nouvel outil
révolutionnaire, l'iPad, qui ouvre
l'ère des tablettes numériques.
On peut donc l'affirmer aujourd'hui
l'iPhone a non seulement sauvé Apple,
mais il en a fait
le leader mondial
sur le marché du smartphone.
Aujourd'hui,
le géant américain n'est plus tout à fait
précurseur
en matière de nouvelles fonctionnalités.
La reconnaissance faciale
ou le poinçon de caméra ont été inventés
par d'autres, mais Apple reste
la marque qui a popularisé le smartphone,
ce qui veut dire beaucoup
pour pas mal de gens.
Là où il se trouve, Steve Jobs doit se frotter les mains.
Merci Léo.
C'était passionnant.
J'ignorais tous les détails
de cette histoire.
Et une fois de plus,
je suis complètement scotché
par le côté visionnaire de Steve Jobs.
Et si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à mettre
un pouce bleu ou à vous abonner
si ce n'est pas encore fait.
Surtout, dites-moi en commentaire
quels sujets tech
vous aimeriez que l'on traite ?
Allez, à très bientôt,
les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.